I'm saying I don't I'm not for abuse so  and completely if it's an abusive  situation that's different yeah but but  I think I think just I think I think  wait okay I think happiness comes and  goes and I think there were a lot of  times my parents have been married 30  years and there have been a lot of times  where my mom maybe wasn't happy for a  couple years or my dad maybe wasn't  happy for a couple years but because of  us they stuck it out and they got  happier and they learned to work it out  and they learn to get along and I think  a lot of times in our society we we  throw in the towel before we've even  really tried and I think that's the  average length of a first marriage is  seven to eight years